want to be a molecular biologist well
you can be at the world's first
community laboratory works a lot like a
gym the idea is that you come whenever
you'd like and you just you pay dues
like you would in a gym using mostly
donated equipment and found materials a
small group of biology enthusiasts
recently created this lab at a warehouse
in Brooklyn New York built the lab right
on this big open space it's it's a big
glass cube all the materials that we've
made it out of our found materials so
glass doors windows that were salvaged
and repurposed 22 points but why would
people want to run lab experiments in
their spare time it is attractive to
people who have ideas that aren't
necessarily useful but they're certainly
fun one of the first projects being
developed by the gen space team is a
device that will be launched by helium
balloons 30 kilometers into the Earth's
stratosphere in search of remote signs
of life the high altitude microbial
sampling station or hands for short is a
weather balloon that's going to be
lofted up to about a hundred thousand
feet into the stratosphere capture
microbes hopefully bring them down in a
sterile package in a sealed package and
then have them analyzed so far the
garage biotechnologists have just built
a prototype of their microbe catcher but
they hope to launch the real deal later
this year gen space is much more than
just a laboratory for do-it-yourselfers
it also provides hands-on educational
courses for people to come and learn
it's not just scientists who are working
in the lab it's people who are bringing
their own curiosity about the world and
bringing it to our lab and exploring the
gen space founders see themselves on the
vanguard of a new movement of DIY
biology so Jenna space is the first
community bio lab but it certainly won't
be the last I I get the sense that there
will be a lot more
popping up all over the country and all
over the world and they think labs like
gin space could revolutionize the study
of biology now that we've reached a
certain level of knowledge in the
information age we've come to the you
know it's open space for another age and
I think that age will be the biological
age and I think you know the next great
pc computer or apple computer won't be a
computer at all it'll be this amazing
bacteria that has this amazing
application that everyone's going to
want to have I don't know what it is yet
if I knew I'd be I wouldn't be talking
to you here for nature medicine I'm a
lead Olga
you